excusez moi il ya quelqu'un là j'ai un
pote farid est pas il est pas là mais il
va arriver donc
désolé cette place je sais pas c'était
mon temps car il faut quelque chose
ouais un coca et du charisme aussi n'en
sais rien c'est juste que j'ai pas car
il faut arrêter avec ça tu a du charisme
et du charisme
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
oui mais voilà il était occupé à temps
excusez moi mademoiselle ça rien à voir
avec le charisme toi tu marmonne t là
s'il vous plaît vous quelque chose oui
moi je vais prendre un demi puis mon ami
prendra un coq à quelqu'un sans de
l'assomption clé ok c'est parti je capte
pas l'attention des gens il me voit et
m'oublie c'est instantané
attends moi je t'ai pas oublier qu'on
s'est rencontrés quand en 2007
je me souviens c'était bizarre bah en
fait on s'est rencontré en 2002 pierre
ses fans
en 2004 pierre powers
on sait déjà des fans en 2004 encore
pierre stéphane en 2005 tiers
c'est stéphane et en 2007 pierre
stéphane donc tu comprends quoi ouais
quand je dis que je captais pas
l'attention des gens non mais c'est
incroyable ça et je la connais la fils
est gay non mais c'est une blague mais
évidemment que c'est une blague
je te rappelle ainsi ainsi aller à
l'amitié à nos rencontres à ta vais
commander un cocard non mais c'est
n'importe quoi ces histoires de charisme
c'est juste que toi tu marches pas sûr
en tête des gens et malheureusement les
gens quand tu les bouscule pas un peu
c'est eux qui le bouscule toi tu penses
aux autres avant de penser à toi
alors ouais on ne remarque pas forcément
tout de suite mais quand on part marqué
va regrette pas parce que tu as un mec
bien
au cas où tu aurais pas séquence en
attendant le conte il invite
moi je vais y est je suis un peu crevé
donc bonjour je vais y aller bref moi je
prends la rose après c'est directement
chez moi donc je sais c'est pas ton
salut quand je vais reprendre d'autres
numéros cochés
j'y vais le saluer carrément ouais les
gars ok d'accord
à givet partie sa voix